hey i'm kevin hi i'm carly hey i'm butch
and today we're going to be drawing a
stranger based only on their voice
and self-description
[Music]
you guys knew that's what we were doing
right no i was told there were donuts
that's all i heard
well why not let's do this i'm ready
okay let's rock and roll let's do it
so let's introduce our stranger for
today stranger go ahead
introduce yourself say hello hi everyone
my name is christine
oh hi christine nice to meet you
nice to meet you too hi christine where
are you joining us from
so i'm from san francisco but right now
i'm in l.a
local l.a have you ever met any of us
before absolutely not well that narrows
it down
so here's how it works christine can't
see our screens we can't see each
other's screens
so the only way we know what to draw is
by what christine tells us
and if you're drawing along at home be
sure to post and tag us on instagram and
twitter
at drawoffshow christine just so we
don't embarrass ourselves could you
please tell us your pronouns and your
ethnicity
sure she her and korean
korean okay how long
uh would you say your hair is where do
you sit say
medium long medium long okay
christine do you wear anything in your
hair normally do you wear like
uh i don't know like decorations or
anything like that no it's usually just
down um
but sometimes i will add some
accessories got it
all right so i think that's enough to
get us started thank you christine
um in the meantime christine tell us
your story are you born and raised in
l.a
i was born and raised in orange county
um but i've been in the bay area for
14 years so i am more san francisco than
la for sure
i'm just here because i go kind of back
and forth what's your profession
my profession is that i'm a circus
performer
why wait hold on hold on
really cool
okay now this is cool okay let me ask
you this when you say performer
are you an acro are you in acrobatics
um yes i do trapeze i do
aerial i do contortion i do
as you call it acrobatics yes that
changes
that change my whole drawing okay wow
okay
i was just gonna draw a bus but now are
we drawing full figures
i guess so upside down right oh no
okay so tell us more about being a
circus performer what circus do you
perform with
so i perform with a bunch um it's not
like uh
i guess a lot of people think of circus
as being like cirque du soleil and
that's the only circus but there's
actually
a ton of circuses i'm more of like an
independent contractor where i run a
circus group and then i work for
at least 40 different agencies and
troops
wow so crazy the circus business
this is like so fascinating to me
i have no idea what to draw now well me
neither so i'm trying to
there's so much range this is yeah okay
give us your uh give us your types of
performance again
flying trapeze is probably my first
circus love
ariel is probably what i'm best at and
what i
like to perform the most now but i also
do compression and hand balancing
hand balancing
i'm going with a a trapeze pose but a
trapeze bow is
based on literally no research ever
this is the first time i've drawn
somebody on trapeze you are
saying the exact same thing i'm thinking
i'm doing the exact same thing i went
trapeze
never drawn anybody out of trapeze
before i don't wow
so what i guess kind of led you to where
you are
now or like what were you doing before
this 14 years ago
i was working in corporate america
and i was taking circus classes for fun
on the side and after a couple years of
training
and i went on vacation with a bunch of
trapeze friends
and i was there for about a week
performing and training
and the the head of the the circus
program pulled me aside and was like
one like we want to hire you like come
join our live
group and i actually laughed at him
because i'm like no
no i'm so serious like i work in an
office like my life is set
and um i got back to new york at the
time i remember opening up my inbox
and at the top of my inbox was a
contract
from the circus wow quit my job
i put in my two week notice and i'm so
glad i did it i love what i do
i love what i do every single day i'm so
grateful that's
amazing how are we doing on our drawings
friends i
am i'm getting there i'm just i know
this doesn't look anything like her
so we don't even know what she looks
like
that's what i'm saying all right so
christine how would you
describe your costume like how how does
that translate over kind of into your
own
personal life at all i love that you
asked um about the
costume and singular so
oh right sorry costumes so as a
performer
we have so many different shows and
looks like i
think i have over 150 costumes whoa
do you have like a favorite at all it's
a circus birthday costume and it's a
white
leotard that's covered in sequin and
rhinestones and it's
beautiful and it's like a full like
covers all the way up to the neck up to
the fingers but yeah that's probably my
most meaningful costume i had that exact
same outfit on last night it was the
weirdest thing
so what ice cream flavor would you say
most
matches your skin tone
probably somewhere between a
caramel and a snickerdoodle oh okay
okay that's also my favorite ice cream
to eat so i don't know if i'm mixing
that up tonight
do you just want some ice cream is that
is that what we're getting at here okay
making me hungry what do you want to do
like 10 years from now would you still
be doing circus stuff
or what what is your big plan what's
your life goal
for me charity and non-profit is a huge
part of my life like i volunteer once a
week no matter what doing something
so i would love to one day have some
kind of
social circus or something for either
kids with disabilities or families with
low socioeconomic statuses and
helping them have opportunities to do
all that so
wow that is my dream that is like my
life
coolest person ever
i want to be christine when i grow up
all right
pens down based on her voice what what
choices did you make
she sounds very perky very upbeat so
that's what i went with i went with a
lot of energy and she said she was from
san fran but now she lives
in l.a i was just like oh okay like i i
don't know she had a
very like la vibe to her all right well
let's uh
send them to each other
wow okay oh look at that
so jealous you guys oh i like carly's
that's really cool carly
oh thank you carly the pose is amazing i
love how dynamic
your poses are i feel like you guys
really pushed the trapeze angle i kind
of coughed out with
like a balancing kind of situation no
that's quick thinking young lady very
quick thinking
let's hear from christine all right i'll
start with butches this one is
super colorful and fun and the body
language is so me
i'm always very excited so i think he
got the energy spot on
kevin's is cracking me up because it's
got like the synchronized
swimming looking head piece
is super cute very cute
a lot of the photos i do so um the
the body position and and what i do is
actually
pretty spot on and she pointed my toes
which i appreciate
yes all right moment of truth
christine you're going to turn on your
camera in a second but if you're playing
along at home be sure to pause here and
finish your drawing
so that way you don't see what christine
looks like before you're done
whenever you're ready turn your camera
on all right
i'll count down three two
one oh my god
look at you oh my gosh wow
i want to change my drawing now okay
glitter glitter
oh this is perfect you did have
something in your hair i knew it
all right christine thank you so much
for being our guest today for a better
look at these drawings
your drawings and to find out how you
could possibly be our next stranger
be sure to hit us up on instagram and
twitter at draw show
christine can you give us a little
acrobatics to play us out
sure he's gonna do a little handstand
[Music]
oh my god wow
[Applause]
the reason why i think my uh my voice
is different is that i have kind of like
a lower more raspy voice
uh and i sound like normal millennial i
probably
sound caucasian because i'm bored and
raised in orange county